FOX NEWS HAS RESPONDED TO FAUCI.
HERE'S RANDI KAYE.
>> NOW YOU'RE GOING FOR THE KILL
SHOT.
THE KILL SHOT WITH AN AMBUSH,
DEADLY.
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T SEE IT
COMING.
>> THAT WAS FOX NEWS HOST JESSE
WATTERS MONDAY NIGHT AT A
TURNING POINT USA CONFERENCE.
WATTERS ASKED THE CROWD TO GO
FOR THE KILL SHOT BY ASKING
AGGRESSIVE QUESTIONS.
>> THIS IS WHEN YOU SAY, DR.
FAUCI, YOU FUNDED RISKY RESEARCH
AT A SLOPPY CHINESE LAB, THE
SAME LAB THAT SPRUNG THIS
PANDEMIC ON THE WORLD.
YOU KNOW WHY PEOPLE DON'T TRUST
YOU, DON'T YOU?
BOOM!
HE IS DEAD!
HE'S DONE.
>> Reporter: FAUCI, WHO IS
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S CHIEF MEDICAL
ADVISER HAD THIS TO SAY IN
RESPONSE.
>> THAT'S HORRIBLE.
I MEAN, THAT JUST IS SUCH A
REFLECTION OF THE CRAZE ZINESS
THAT GOES ON IN SOCIETY.
>> Reporter: FAUCI HAS SERVED
MORE THAN THREE DECADES AS THE
NATION'S TOP INFECTIOUS DISEASE
DOCTOR.
ALL HE'S EVER DONE IS ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO GET VACCINATED AND
WEAR A MASK IN PUBLIC SETTINGS.
>> FOR THAT YOU HAVE A GUY
SAYING PEOPLE SHOULD BE GIVING
ME A KILL SHOT TO AMBUSH ME.
WHATEVER NETWORK HE'S ON IS NOT
GOING TO DO ANYTHING FOR HIM.
THE GUY SHOULD BE FIRED ON THE
SPOT.
>> FOX NEWS IS DEFENDING
WATTERS, SAYING HE WAS USING A
METAPHOR AND HIS WORDS HAVE BEEN
TWISTED COMPLETELY OUT OF
CONTEXT.
CNN LAW ENFORCEMENT ANALYST
DISAGREES.
>> IT'S JUST FUELLING MOB RULE
TO SATISFY A POLITICAL GOAL.
>> DR. FAUCI'S BEEN ATTACKED BY
FOX HOSTS SINCE NEARLY THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC.
MOST RECENTLY IT WAS LARA LOGAN,
WHO LAST MONTH USED HER SHOW ON
THE CHANNEL'S STREAMING NETWORK
TO COMPARE FAUCI TO A NAZI
DOCTOR NOUN AS THE ANGEL OF
DEATH AT AUSCHWITZ FOR HIS
BRUTAL EXPERIMENTS ON PRISONERS.
>> PEOPLE SAY TO ME HE DOESN'T
REPRESENT SCIENCE TO ME.
HE REPRESENTS THE NAZI DOCTOR
WHO DID EXPERIMENTS ON JEWS
DURING THE SECOND WORLD WAR.
>> AFTER THAT FOX STAYED SILENT
AND LARA LOGAN CONTINUED TO
DEMONIZE FAUCI.
THEN SHE APPEARED TO BE QUIETLY
REMOVED FROM AIR, AT LEAST
TEMPORARILY.
>> HOW THEY CAN LET HER SAY THAT
WITH NO COMMENT AND NO
DISCIPLINARY ACTION, I'M
ASTOUNDED BY THAT.
>> Reporter: AND ALL THE
RHETORIC HAS COME AT A COST.
FAUCI HAS RECEIVED DEATH
THREATS, AND IT'S PUT HIS ENTIRE
FAMILY AT RISK.
>> EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE YOU
STOP AND YOU THINK ABOUT IT AND
YOU SAY, MY WORLD HAS COMPLETELY
CHANGED.
BUT AS IT'S CHANGING, YOU DON'T
REALIZE IT'S CHANGING BECAUSE
YOU'RE JUST FOCUSING.
WE'VE GOT TO GET A VACCINE.
WE'VE GOT TO GET A DRUG.
WE'VE GOT TO DO THIS.
WE'VE GOT TO DO THAT.
AND EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE YOU
SAY, WELL, WAIT A MINUTE, I'VE
GOT TWO ARMED SECURITY GUARDS
HERE.
I'VE GOT ANOTHER GUY OVER THERE.
>> Reporter: SINCE MARCH OF LAST
YEAR, FAUCI HAS HAD SECURITY
DETAIL FOR EXTRA PROTECTION.
COMMENTS LIKE WATTERS' PERHAPS
MAKING THAT ALL THE MORE
NECESSARY.
>> THE POTENTIAL FOR SUCH
PHRASES TO TRANSFORM FROM
RHETORIC INTO DESTRUCTIVENESS OR
PHYSICAL HARM, WE'VE SEEN THAT
TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
PEOPLE WILL CO-OPT THAT FOR A
CALL TO ACTION AND HARM AGAINST
DR. FAUCI.
>> AND RANDI KAYE JOINS US NOW.
RANDI, DO THESE THREATS TO DR.
FAUCI GO BEYOND JUST THE
RHETORIC WE HEAR FROM PEOPLE ON
TV?
>> ABSOLUTELY JOHN WE ARE SEEING
THAT.
OVER THE SUMMER THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FILED A FEDERAL
COMPLAINT AGAINST A 56-YEAR-OLD
MARYLAND MAN.
AND ACCORDING TO THE AFFIDAVIT
THIS MAN HAD MADE THREATS TO
FAUCI AND HIS FAMILY THAT HE
WOULD HARM OR KILL THEM.
ACCORDING TO THE AFFIDAVIT, ONE
EMAIL SAID HE WOULD DRAG THEM TO
THE STREET, BEAT THEM TO DEATH,
AND THEN SET THEM ON FIRE.
THE AFFIDAVIT ALSO SAYS THIS MAN
SENT SEVEN THREATENING EMAILS IN
SEVEN MINUTES ON A SINGLE DAY IN
APRIL.
SEPARATE FROM THAT, DR. FAUCI
HAD RECEIVED WHITE POWDER IN THE
MAIL THAT HE DESCRIBED AS
BLOWING UP IN HIS FACE.
OF COURSE THERE WAS CONCERN
THERE WAS THE DANGEROUS ANTHRAX.
IT TURNED OUT TO BE HARMLESS.
BUT THESE AR